we normally don't have everyday someone
you know as famous that you know a noble
sign is coming down
by the day we were pretty good Isis it
was great to meet the students of madre
University on the one hand they were you
know so serious so committed ambitious
about the careers looking forward to
really getting a lot done and on the
other hand they I felt a sense of
playfulness and energy they weren't they
weren't drab it was a really really
appealing combination
we never thought like we would see a
novel or a into the college like dream
coming into reality it was good to be
with him the two days I enjoyed a lot
yeah my opinion was like he's a very
great person a Nobel laureate and that
proved in physics so it should be very
brainy very formal and I never expected
him to come down and talk to us if you
go far away from the stars far away from
the nearest center of galaxies into the
distant deepest faced the lowest
temperature you'll find in a natural way
is three degrees Kelvin I want to
emphasize that where we're going is so
far from the world that we're accustomed
to things get very strange down there it
inspired us so much that we like you
really felt like dropping on a study
than going on going for us an awful
price in our research to work so people
are really ignite and everyone wants to
this is bull same Stein and Bulls being
an Indian topic the bows in
bose-einstein condensation is Sachi and
would not bows and come to the country
of Moses origin where he actually did
the work and led eventually to the
concepts of Bose Einstein statistics on
which bose-einstein condensation is is
born that was special this is a cloud at
about 400 nano Kelvin and then as we got
colder the central peak appeared we got
colder even yet and this very narrow
peak appeared this was the first of all
a sign kind of say let's try and explain
bose-einstein condensation and the
simplest possible terms I could say it's
it's what happens when you get things so
cold so very very cold that it's quantum
mechanical nature which is the inner
waviness that lurks inside every
particle trying to get out start to
overlap with each other and make one
giant atom wave we can think of the
individual atoms much like these these
rose petals here these petals of a
flower which are floating hither and
thither and a not especially organized
way but as we get them colder and colder
the petals begin to overlap with one
another they start to become in this
respect more organized until eventually
the individual rose petals aren't the
thing anymore instead you see the single
collective beautiful object which is a
rose it's a bit of a stretch but you
could think of this rose as being
something like a bose-einstein
condensate of rose petals
what is it like being a pioneer in your
field well it's it's thrilling to me -
for me this was a culmination of a
lifetime ambition at times it can be a
little scary or even a little bit lonely
because usually if you're a pioneer
you're doing things that are in some
sense maybe not traditional maybe are
maybe wrong that can be a frightening
experience I've had a couple experiments
that that have failed miserably and it's
important not to be afraid of that but
to continue to have large ambitions and
willingness to have things collapse
around you spectacularly it's been a
great exposure to all of this that
you've conducted a such an open program
bringing the noble scientists all over
here into India and such to moderate
because we haven't had so much exposure
till now so I'd really like to thank
Honeywell for that what do you like
about India about India a big fan of
Indian food but more than Indian food I
really like Indians we're always told
that we're not supposed to make
generalizations about nationalities but
I can't help myself
I think Indians are just really nice
people it's like me being Indian it's a
country I find it very easy to be
optimistic about just because of this
this vast resource which is the Indians
collectively as a people they value
education they appreciate research and
knowledge and understanding these are
things that you want to have as you move
into the future and this it's a country
that has those qualities and abundance
it's good to see really